هو تطور لافت تشهده ساحه المعركه في
اوكرانيا استهداف شبه جزيره القرم طبعا
وفقا لما سمعناها الان من تصريحات روسيه
هذه الهجمات كانت بطائرات مسيره باتجاه
شبه جزيره القرم ليست هذه المره الاولى
التي تهاجم فيها القرم اعلنت روسيا احباط
هجمات مماثله بالمسيرات قبل نحو اسبوعين
طبعا لطالما وضعت روسيا القرم ضمن خطوطها
الحمراء
نتذكر هنا تصريحات لافته للرئيس الروسي
السابق ونائب رئيس المجلس الامن القومي
الحالي قال فيها ان الهجوم على القرم
سياتي بيوم القيامه سريعا كما انتقدت
موسكو فيما مضى ايضا تصريحات امريكيه
اعتبرت القرم هدفا مشروعا لكياف وكان رد
الفعل الروسي عنيفا عندما قامت
عندما شهدنا تفجير جسر كيرش هنا في هذه
المنطقه الذي يربط شبه جزيره القرم بالبر
الروسي في روسيا حيث بدات موسكو في ذلك
الوقت باستهداف كامل البنى التحتيه في
اوكرانيا بشكل كبير طيب نتجه الان الى
الشرق ايضا حيث التطورات ليست اقل شانا
خساره القوات الاوكرانيه لباخمت ان وقعت
قد تعتبر الحدث الاكبر بعد معركه في
باخموت هي الاطول خلال الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا بمده تزيد عن سته اشهر من اكثر
المعارك دمويه ايضا ان لم تكن اكثرها على
الاطلاق كيف وصلت الامور الى هنا ما الذي
جرى في باقي خلال الاسابيع الاخيره تقول
ان ميليشيا فاجنر استخدمت اكثر قواتها
استعدادا في هذه الهجمات من شفاجنر تقول
انها استطاعت تحقيق المزيد من المكاسب
الجغرافيه بسيطرتها يهدني هنا
وبير خوفك هنا في الشمال وبالتالي الان
لدينا هذا اللسان الذي تشاهدونه بخموت
مواقع القوات الاوكرانيه طبعا هنا تبعدان
نحو خمسه كيلومترات او سبعه كيلو مترات عن
وسط ضخمه تقول وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
هذا التقدم جعل طرق الامداد هذه الطرق
التي ترونها لباخمت تحت سيطرتها الناريه
من الجانبين بالتالي الان تقول ميليشيا
فاجنر انها تتقدم على جبهتين الجبهه
الشماليه هنا كما تشاهدون وايضا من الجبهه
الشرقيه هنا باتجاه هذا النهر نهر اذا
لماذا تسر موسكو على السيطره على
هذه المدينه الصناعيه باخمت شهيره بصناعات
التعدين طبعا تلعب دورا مهما في خطوط
الامداد على جبهه معارك دومباس عموما
والوصول اليها سيفتح الطريق للقوات
الروسيه للوص الى المعقلين الرئيسيين
للقوات الاوكرانيه في دونيسك
وكراماتورسك وهذا سيمكنها بالتاكيد من
السيطره بشكل شبه كامل على منطقه حاليا هي
تسيطر على نحو
54% منها وبالتالي اكمال السيطره عموما
على اقليم دومباس كذلك ستشكل باخمه نصر
الرمزيا مهما
لروسيا لاسيما بعد اشهر من توقف تقدمها
العسكري وخسارتها العديد من المناطق في
خييرسون وشرق خار كيف